bene senti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
video sono vari generi stati su knock
out city perché è incredibile conto
hamas con stern i gol di fuji nazione è
sono morti in 12 occhio sbagliati ok ci
ha liberato non lo so come sono andato
tutto ok a telescope è morto da una
volta anche questa tensione tra la gente
e prima era questa morte sta recuperando
la campagna mi hanno schiacciato dove
sono dove sono andati in b sky sono
state solo però
ma porca vacca ripresa fuori della
capitale
pazzesco ragazze ricopra un fatto
facciamole modellare puntata come loro
non si sa come hanno fatto per ora store
di erano ancora uscito un pugno su
questo gioco è rimasto colpito morto dai
38 dai bravo ciancimino alla presa presa
così è morto bravo 58 dai ragazzi
ricevono mosso clementi dove sono
lanciate sono occhi anche l'ora della
partita dai not on our fuori ha un cuore
19 l'ho colpito
non capite morto a 89 non morite a uno
solo di vita 12 a 1 di vita 21 di vita
beh mi avevi as the five este eliminato
un bravo 10 9 madonna remuntada da una
rimonta dall'altra pazzesco e
incredibile ci pensa però ora che
all'ultima è pazzesca colpito uno capo
da cecchino
non ci credo io l'ho mancato dai ragazzi
no c'era il ma macchina non ci credo o
che hanno colpito marco 3 3 dai c'è la
macchina incredibile bravissimo donna
lancia vista non fatte o cosa vabbè se
lo merita
milan ci fanno attenzione ciancimino ha
colpito eliminato uno bravissimi ritiro
che ha trasformato colpito
eliminato un'altra 3 3 poi pallone
incredibile incredibile colpito morto
opera e bellissima bellissima colpito
nice
no è un bellissimo lo sfiato
un'incredibile anno si sono avuti dopo
vieni qua vi ricordo di madonna
bellissimo dai ragazzi punto se vuoi
tomtom lancia bilancia mi no per niente
malcontento 95 dai match point colpito
al nostro vinto visto disponibile su cd
non ci capisce lo scappando dai non lo
dirò come 98 nagano e 8 di vento li
vedono in una palla
mamma mia mamma mia che partita madonna
bravissimo bravissimo bravissimo
bellissima no non è no non è per questo
città da è possibile non è possibile che
non sia morto ed elisa schiantato del
dente nelle mutande invece qualche
escamotage per schivare sta roba che non
so
si no l'ultimo di farlo ora ho giocato
anch'io 11 dai live dove la gente allora
giusta ma dobbiamo in arrivo
no grazie ho fatto è stata bellissima
fatto nazione pazzesca mi sono
emozionato da solo da attenzione se
c'era 146 morto fra via montorio
fatturazione pazzesca prima però mai più
a franz e arrivo ragazzo dovesse la
gente mi vantaggio o in freud morto
morto anche questo pensiamo doppio ko a
questa lo fila
ma non è morto attenzione la gara può
morire tom tom
bravo tom bravo ton
ancora ko la presa ma ha messo ko a me
occhio o kg è stata ora allora fatto in
tempo a dire tutto fari non so che mi
ami ami notiamo li vai al momento ci
siamo capiti 2 praga 2 in 2 a una vita
sano chi produce ok
uno è morto il ragazzo sta una vita dai
normale non male un male questo era un
capo scappa scappa scappa la mattinata
in territorio 10 9 l'ex colonia raio
dobbiamo team archer messa vicini
secondo me no prendiamo raccontiamo
cerchiai
no al muro presa non ci credo che mi
abbia preso così non è italiano questo
ok colpito bella abbiamo benji
incredibili crediti incredibile
incredibile fortissimo questo ma chi è
vabbè una fila di ambiente bello
ok uno ha colpito la comunità una hit
tonietto sono morto perché lui è ninja
facebook mancando stop mancando capito
le scocche team è bellissimo amore nice
bella bella bella bella vi fate sognare
bellissimo equity ragazzi anche oggi il
video di kakà al city finisce qua spero
vi sia piaciuto ragazzi sta veramente è
bellissimo è veramente bello cioè vorrei
portare tre episodi ma fatelo sapere nei
commenti
i schede a caccia del mi piace qua sotto
e noi come sempre ci vediamo al prossimo
video era mai ormai prendo tutto e che
sono abituato a prendere le palle ma
arrivano e quindi let's golf non vedo
l'ora di giocare di nuovo bene
[Musica]